it's been five years now since the white
smoke at the Sistine Chapel indicated
that a new pope had been named tonight
Bret Baier talks with Washington
Archbishop Cardinal Donald Wuerl about
the first five years of Pope Francis and
what lies ahead Brett thanks John
tomorrow is the fifth anniversary of
pope francis's election to talk about
that joining me now Cardinal Donald
Wuerl Archbishop of Washington at the
weigh in on the last five years of this
papacy Cardinal thanks so much for being
here well you're welcome it's a great
joy to be back to be with you and to
think celebrating the fifth anniversary
of Pope Francis I think the the impact
of Pope Francis is people see in him he
lives the faith he he bears witness with
his life not just his words and his
whole impact as I see it is he's opened
up the church in a way that people feel
they're much more welcome he says to the
space for all of us here in this church
I've seen the map of his travel it is
quite something
it's extensive it is and when he was
elected he said I don't think I will be
moving around as much as previous Pope's
and that turned out not to be true at
all he for as old as he is he continues
to carry out the schedule of some 120
years younger and he's having any impact
everywhere he goes with President Trump
and president Trump remarks with the
conversation that they had there are
some conservatives I guess you would say
inside the u.s. who are skeptical of
some of the the politics perhaps from
how he expresses that ideology sometimes
how do you deal with that for your
congregations here talking about
ideology and politics when it comes to
the Pope one of the wonderful things
though about Pope Francis is he doesn't
seem to be inhibited
by categories by labeling he says what
he thinks on a particular topic and he
sense it not in political terms and not
in any logical terms now you're right
there are those who would put that try
to put it into one of those categories
but I think that's one of the attractive
things about Pope Francis people realize
he's just speaking from his heart it's
not from some preconceived plan about
his age but he is also active on social
media the Vatican very active on Twitter
on Friday he tweeted out with so much to
do we often neglect what is really
important our spiritual lives and our
relationship with God so let's stop and
take time to pray that's at the heart of
his life he told us that a meeting that
he takes an hour before supper every
night to simply be in the chapel and he
said you know sometimes at the end of
the day I'm so tired I began to doze off
but he said it doesn't matter God knows
I'm there you're there what do you think
he would say about the world the u.s.
all over and what we've seen in recent
years sort of a secularization and
concern from many parents and many
communities that there is a fall away
from not only the church but but this
higher meaning he I think would be the
first one to say there's been this
dramatic this dramatic secularization it
doesn't bring out the best of people
the difficulty with a holy secularized
culture is it doesn't leave space for
the realization we're all brothers and
sisters because we're all children of
God I think he often says we need we
need to be conscious of the fact
in a secular environment we could easily
forget the most important thing and
that's our soul and our relationship to
God and we have to work at that every
single day Colonel Donald Wuerl we
appreciate you coming in on this
anniversary of the Pope's election and
please give them our best I will do that
thank you so very much god bless